Is it me or do you have a good ear? Maybe it's just an impression, but the song likes to relax the sound of people who talk to you about super captivating topics for hours. It sounds good, because I have something really interesting for you. The first mobility service by subscription to the country offered by the mobile audience. Yes, of course. At Star, you can subscribe to your 5G forfeiture without being attached. Mobile audience.
是我还是你听力挺好的？也许这只是个错觉，不过这首歌喜欢舒缓那些跟你聊超级迷人话题好几个小时的人的声音。这听起来不错，因为我这儿正好有特别吸引你的内容。这是由Mobile Audience在全国首推的按月付费移动服务。当然啦。在Star，你无需绑定合同就能订阅5G套餐。Mobile Audience。
To you, the difference. Or on our website. This episode involves a crime against children. It may not be suitable for all listeners. There was excitement in the air as Marion Sodder returned home following her shift at the local dollar store on Christmas Eve 1945. 17-year-old Marion handed out gifts she had bought from work to her younger siblings, who persuaded their parents, George and Jenny, to let them open a few early. The family of 12 had an extra reason to celebrate Christmas that year.
带给你与众不同的体验。或者访问我们的网站。本期节目涉及针对儿童的犯罪。可能不适合所有听众。1945年平安夜，当马里昂·索德结束了当地一元店的值班回到家时，空气中弥漫着兴奋的气氛。17岁的马里昂把从工作单位买的礼物分发给弟弟妹妹们，他们说服了父母乔治和珍妮，让他们提前打开几件礼物。这个12口之家当年过圣诞节还有一个额外的理由。
World War II had ended only three months prior. It wouldn't be long before the Sodder's second oldest son, Joseph, who had been serving in the US Army, returned home to Fayetteville, West Virginia. As the night wore on, two of the older Sodder sons, John and George Jr, retired to bed. They had spent the day helping their father with work and were tired. The pair headed up into the attic, which was used as a space for the many Sodder children to sleep. The attic was divided into two rooms and accessible via a set of stairs. George Sr. also went to bed at this time, in the master bedroom on the main floor.
第二次世界大战在仅仅三个月前刚刚结束。要不了多久，索德家的二儿子约瑟夫就会从美国陆军退伍，回到西弗吉尼亚州费耶特维尔的家中。夜深了，索德家的两个大儿子约翰和小乔治上床睡觉了。他们花了一整天时间帮父亲干活，已经累了。两人上到了阁楼，那里是索德家众多孩子睡觉的地方。阁楼被隔成两个房间，可以通过一组楼梯上去。老乔治此时也上床睡觉了，睡在主楼层的主卧室里。
His wife followed shortly thereafter at around 10.30pm, taking their three-year-old daughter, Sylvia, with her. The other Sodder children, Morris, Martha, Lewis, Jenny and Betty, continued to play with their new toys. Marion lay on the couch, keeping an eye on the youngsters who ranged from 5 to 14 years old. At about 12.30am, Jenny woke to the sound of the telephone ringing in her husband's study next to the master bedroom. She got up to answer it and was met on the line by a woman whose voice she didn't recognise. In the background were the sounds of laughing and chatter and of glass clinking. The caller asked for someone who didn't reside at the Sodder residence. When Jenny told her she had the wrong number, the woman laughed strangely before hanging up.
他的妻子紧随其后，大约在晚上10点30分上楼，并带上了他们三岁的女儿西尔维娅。索德家的其他孩子莫里斯、玛莎、刘易斯、珍妮和贝蒂则继续玩着他们的新玩具。马里昂躺在沙发上，照看着年龄从5岁到14岁不等的小家伙们。大约凌晨12点30分，珍妮被主卧室隔壁她丈夫书房里的电话铃声吵醒。她起来接电话，电话那头是一个她听不出来的女人的声音。背景音里传来欢笑声、聊天声以及玻璃碰撞声。来电者询问了一个并不住在索德家的人。当珍妮告诉她打错电话时，那个女人发出奇怪的笑声，然后挂断了电话。
As she left the study, Jenny realised the lights were still on in the family room where the children had been playing. The front door was also unlocked. Usually the job of the last family member to go to bed, Jenny walked past Marion who was sleeping on the sofa and locked the door and turned off the lights. Assuming all her other children were asleep in the attic, Jenny went back to bed. A light sleeper, Jenny was disrupted again 30 minutes later at around 1am on Christmas morning. What sounded like a hard rubber ball landed on the tar and wood roof of the family's cottage. It rolled down the roof. Then there was silence. Exhausted, Jenny ignored the noise, rolling over and going back to sleep.
当她离开书房时，珍妮发现孩子们刚才玩耍的家庭活动室里的灯还亮着。前门也没有锁。这通常是家里最后一个人睡觉时要做的事，珍妮走过睡在沙发上的马里昂，锁上了门，关掉了灯。珍妮以为其他孩子都在阁楼上睡着了，于是便回房睡觉了。作为一个觉浅的人，珍妮在30分钟后，也就是圣诞节早晨1点左右再次被惊醒。有什么听起来像硬橡胶球的东西落在了这家人小木屋的柏油木质屋顶上。它从屋顶滚了下来。接着是一片寂静。筋疲力尽的珍妮没有理会这个声音，翻个身又睡着了。
30 minutes later at 1.30am, Jenny woke to the smell of smoke. She followed the trail and found it was coming from George's study which was on fire. She raced back to her room and roused George. He in turn woke Marion who was still sleeping on the sofa. She took three-year-old Sylvia outside to safety. Jenny yelled frantically at the bottom of the attic stairs for the seven children above to come down. The fire was moving quickly and was already starting to take hold of the stairs. After what seemed an eternity, John and George Jr. made their way down. Their hair was singed from the flames. Meanwhile, George Sr. attempted to call the local fire department only to find the phone line to the Sotter House was dead.
30分钟后，即凌晨1点30分，珍妮闻到了一股烟味。她顺着气味找去，发现气味来自正在着火的乔治的书房。她跑回房间叫醒了乔治。乔治随即叫醒了还在沙发上睡觉的马里昂。马里昂带着三岁的西尔维娅去屋外安全的地方。珍妮在阁楼楼梯底部疯狂大喊，让楼上的七个孩子快下来。火势蔓延得极快，已经开始吞噬楼梯了。经过漫长得仿佛一个世纪的煎熬，约翰和小乔治终于跑了下来。他们的头发都被火焰烧焦了。与此同时，老乔治试图给当地消防局打电话，却发现索德家的电话线已经断了。
Marion sprinted to their closest neighbour who also tried to call but the phone went unanswered by the operator. Another neighbour who was still awake saw the Sotter House going up in flames and also attempted to phone the fire department. But again, there was no operator response. George Sr. was forced to retreat from the house when the flames and smoke became too intense. Four of his children and his wife were safe outside in the freezing winter night. But his five children who had been up late playing with their toys remained in the attic. Attempts to control the fire with water from the outside rain barrel proved fruitless. It was frozen solid.
马里昂飞奔去找最近的邻居，邻居也试图打电话，但接线员一直没有接听。另一个还没睡觉的邻居看到索德家陷入火海，也试图给消防局打电话。但同样，接线员没有任何回应。当火焰和浓烟变得极其猛烈时，老乔治被迫撤出了房子。他的四个孩子和妻子在冰冷的冬夜里安全地待在外面。但他的五个因为玩玩具玩得很晚而留在阁楼里的孩子却没有出来。用外面雨水桶里的水灭火的尝试证明是徒劳的。水已经冻成实心的了。
Instead, George Sr. realised he might be able to climb up to the exterior attic window. He ran around to the side of the house where he always kept his trusty ladder. It was gone. George had another idea. He jumped into one of his two coal trucks thinking he could reverse it up to the house and climb on top to reach the attic window. He inserted the key into the ignition but the truck wouldn't start. He tried his second coal truck. It wouldn't start either.
相反，老乔治意识到自己或许可以爬到阁楼的外窗。他跑到房子侧面，那里一直放着他信赖的梯子。梯子不见了。乔治有了另一个主意。他跳上他的两辆运煤卡车之一，心想可以把车倒开到房子旁边，然后爬到车顶去够阁楼的窗户。他把钥匙插进点火开关，但卡车打不着火。他又试了第二辆运煤卡车。同样也打不着火。
Both had been working perfectly fine the previous day. Meanwhile, one of the neighbours, frustrated at not being able to reach an operator, drove into the town of Fayetteville and tracked down F.J. Morris, the fire chief. He alerted his volunteer fire team using a commonplace practice at the time. One fireman would call another, who would in turn call another, until a team was assembled. Unfortunately, many of the volunteer firefighters had yet to return from war. The department was severely understaffed. Although the fire station was just over two miles from the Sotter family home,
前一天两辆车都运转得好好的。与此同时，其中一位邻居因为联系不上接线员而急坏了，便开车直奔费耶特维尔镇，寻找消防队长F·J·莫里斯。他用当时一种常见的方法警示了志愿消防队。一个消防员打电话给另一个消防员，后者再打给下一个，直到组建起一支队伍。不幸的是，许多志愿消防员还没从战场上回来。消防部门严重人手不足。尽管消防局距离索德家只有两英里多，
fire chief F.J. Morris could not attend alone as he couldn't drive the fire truck. George and Jenny Sotter could do nothing more than watch the inferno helplessly. Within 45 minutes, the roof crashed down to the basement level. Their house was completely destroyed. As daylight broke on Christmas Day 1945, all that was left of the Sotter house was ash and ruins. The Fayetteville fire department arrived at 8am, six and a half hours after the fire started, long after anything could be done to rescue the children or salvage the property. George Sotter Sr. was treated at the local hospital for lacerations to his arm,
消防队长F·J·莫里斯无法独自前往，因为他不会开消防车。老乔治和珍妮·索德只能眼睁睁地看着这场大火却无能为力。在45分钟内，屋顶塌陷到了地下室水平。他们的房子被完全摧毁了。当1945年圣诞节的曙光破晓时，索德家剩下的只有灰烬和废墟。费耶特维尔消防局在早上8点到达，也就是火灾发生六个半小时后，远在任何能够拯救孩子或抢救财产的努力都为时已晚的时候。老乔治·索德因手臂划伤在当地医院接受了治疗，
sustained while trying to reach his trapped children. Fire marshals and local police combed the wreckage for an hour. Fire chief F.J. Morris and his team failed to find any human remains, explaining to George and Jenny that their children's bones must have completely disintegrated from the heat and intensity of the fire. Newspapers throughout the United States reported on the tragedy. The Fayetteville County prosecutor announced there would be an investigation into the deaths of 14-year-old Morris, 12-year-old Martha, 9-year-old Lewis, 8-year-old Jenny and 5-year-old Betty. A coroner's jury was assembled who concluded the cause of the fire to be faulty electrical wiring,
这些伤是在他试图营救被困孩子时受到的。消防局长和当地警察在废墟中搜查了一个小时。消防队长F·J·莫里斯和他的团队未能找到任何人类遗骸，他们向乔治和珍妮解释说，他们孩子的骨头一定已经在火灾的高温和猛烈烈火中彻底融化了。全美国的报纸都报道了这场悲剧。费耶特维尔县检察官宣布将对14岁的莫里斯、12岁的玛莎、9岁的刘易斯、8岁的珍妮和5岁的贝蒂的死因展开调查。一个验尸陪审团随后成立，他们得出结论，火灾原因是电路故障，
likely originating in the home study at the rear of the house. Strong winds were blamed for causing the quick acceleration of the fire. On December 30, 1945, George and Jenny Sotter were issued five death certificates for each of their deceased children. Their cause of death was listed as, quote, death by suffocation or fire which completely destroyed the home in which they were sleeping. As no remains had been found, the Fayetteville County prosecutor assured the Sotters a more thorough investigation would be completed in the new year, once the festive season had ended. A week later and against the wishes of authorities, George went to work to cover the site of their former home,
很可能是从房子后方的家庭书房开始的。强风被认为是导致火势迅速蔓延的原因。1945年12月30日，老乔治和珍妮·索德收到了他们五个已故孩子的死亡证明。他们的死因被列为，引述，“因窒息或火灾导致他们睡觉的房屋完全损毁而死亡。”由于没有找到遗骸，费耶特维尔县检察官向索德夫妇保证，节日季结束后，将在新年进行更彻底的调查。一周后，违背当局的意愿，乔治去清理他们以前的房屋所在地，
unable to look at the wreckage any longer. Using a bulldozer, George emptied five feet of dirt on top of the ashes to fill what once was the basement. The Sotters then created a memorial garden and shrine at the site. George built another house on his property, but in a new location. The surviving Sotters tried to move on with their lives. However, as the shock wore off, George and Jenny were left with an uneasy feeling. They were certain that the fire that destroyed their house and killed their children was not an accident. There were others in the community who felt that way too.
再也无法直视这片废墟。乔治用推土机在灰烬上倒了五英尺厚的泥土，填平了曾经的地下室。索德夫妇随后在遗址上建造了一个纪念花园和神殿。乔治在自己的土地上建了另一所房子，但换了个新地方。幸存的索德家人试图继续他们的生活。然而，随着震惊渐渐消退，乔治和珍妮心中留有一种不安的感觉。他们确信，毁掉他们的房子并夺走孩子生命的火灾绝不是一场意外。社区里也有其他人持这种看法。
One such person was a local bus driver. He described what he called balls of fire being thrown by a group of people at the Sotter house. Whether or not this lead was followed up by authorities is not known. A few months after the blaze, the snow blanketing the region began to thaw. Three-year-old Sylvia was playing near the site of her former home when she found something that had previously been concealed by the snow. About the size of a baseball and made of dark green hard rubber, the object was hollow with a screw cap. Sylvia showed it to her parents. George thought he recognized the object and took it to a military official to confirm his belief.
其中一个人是当地的一名公交车司机。他描述了自己所说的被一群人扔向索德家的“火球”。当局是否跟进了这条线索不得而知。火灾发生几个月后，覆盖该地区的积雪开始融化。三岁的西尔维娅在以前的家附近玩耍时，发现了一件之前被雪掩盖的东西。这个物件大约棒球大小，由深绿色硬橡胶制成，是中空的，带有螺旋盖。西尔维娅把它拿给父母看。乔治觉得这东西眼熟，便把它拿给一位军事官员来证实自己的猜测。
The object was a type of grenade, sometimes referred to as a pineapple bomb. George was certain this was the noise Jenny heard on the roof just before the fire broke out. He also concluded that the unknown woman who phoned the Sotter house earlier that night was calling to make sure they were home before the fire was lit. Adding to George and Jenny's speculation that the fire was a deliberate act was the ladder that was always kept by the side of the house. It was later found thrown down an embankment approximately 80 feet away, seemingly discarded by someone so it couldn't be found. On the night of the fire, but before it was set, a man had been witnessed stealing a block and tackle from George's shed on the property. George used the items as a pulley system to work on his coal trucks. He speculated that his trucks might have been tampered with by the man, causing them not to work during the blaze.
这个物体是一种手榴弹，有时被称为菠萝弹。乔治确信这就是火灾爆发前珍妮在屋顶上听到的声音。他还推断，那天晚上早些时候给索德家打电话的那个陌生女人，是为了在点火前确认他们是否在家。加剧乔治和珍妮对这场大火是有预谋的猜测的，是那个总是放在房屋侧面的梯子。后来它被发现在大约80英尺外的一个路堤下，似乎是被某人故意丢弃以防被发现。在火灾当晚、但大火点燃之前，曾有人目击一名男子从乔治在房产上的棚子里偷走了一个滑轮组。乔治用这些物件作为滑轮系统来修理他的运煤卡车。他推测他的卡车可能被那名男子做了手脚，导致它们在火灾期间无法启动。
No investigation was conducted on the trucks to see if they had been tampered with, or if it was simply the cold night air that caused them not to start. However, the thief, a local man named Lonnie Johnson, was later arrested and charged for the theft of the block and tackle. While being questioned by police, he also admitted to cutting the Sotter's electric line, despite the claims by George and Jenny Sotter, who said the electricity was on as the house burnt down. Jenny later said, We would never have gotten out of there alive if the lights had been cut. After the fire, a telephone repairman was called out to attend to a hanging telephone line. They informed the Sotters that the phone line had been cut, explaining why George and Jenny couldn't call for the fire department during the blaze. To cause this damage, someone had declined the telegraph pole, which was over 14 feet high.
并没有对卡车进行调查，以查看它们是否被人动过手脚，或者是否仅仅是寒冷的夜空气导致它们无法启动。然而，小偷——一个名叫朗尼·约翰逊的当地男子——后来因盗窃滑轮组而被捕并受到指控。在接受警方讯问时，他甚至承认割断了索德家的电线，尽管老乔治和珍妮·索德坚称房子燃烧时家里是有电的。珍妮后来表示：“如果电线被割断了，我们绝不可能活着逃出来。”火灾发生后，曾叫来一名电话修理工来处理一根垂落的电话线。他们通知索德夫妇，电话线被割断了，这解释了为什么乔治和珍妮在火灾期间无法给消防局打电话。为了造成这种破坏，有人爬上了14英尺高的高压电线杆。
The Sotters believed that Lonnie Johnson had cut the phone lines by accident, thinking it was the electric line. Johnson pleaded guilty to cutting the line, but denied stealing the block and tackle. Nevertheless, he was fined $25. Even though the Sotters were convinced their house was intentionally set alight, they were uncertain as to who might be responsible. As far as they were aware, their middle-class family was well respected within their close-knit community. Both the George and Jenny were Italian immigrants who wound up in Fayetteville, where they met and fell in love. They had their first child, John, in 1923, before going on to have another nine children. George was an intelligent man, unafraid of a hard day's work.
索德夫妇认为朗尼·约翰逊是误以为电线而意外割断了电话线。约翰逊对割断电线供认不讳，但否认偷了滑轮组。尽管如此，他还是被罚款25美元。尽管索德夫妇坚信他们的房子是被人故意纵火的，但他们不确定谁应当对此负责。据他们所知，他们这个中产阶级家庭在紧密团结的社区里备受尊崇。乔治和珍妮都是意大利移民，最终在费耶特维尔落脚，在那里他们相遇并坠入爱河。他们在1923年有了第一个孩子约翰，之后又生了九个孩子。乔治是一个聪明的人，不怕吃苦。
From the moment he arrived in the US at age 13, he labored to build his own American dream. He worked in Pennsylvania on the railway, before moving to West Virginia where he began his own trucking business, moving dirt and other construction materials around various sites. He settled in Fayetteville, drawn in by its large population of Italian immigrants. Although theirs was a happy life, the Sotta family still faced difficulties. This led them to question if anyone around them might have reason to hurt them. Weeks before the fire, on a cool, fall day, George Sotta was suddenly disrupted by the sound of knocking. It was coming from the front door. At his doorstep was a young man he didn't recognize.
从他13岁到达美国的那一刻起，他就努力建立自己的美国梦。他曾在宾夕法尼亚州修铁路，后来搬到西弗吉尼亚州，在那里开始了自己的卡车运输业务，在各个工地运送泥土和其他建筑材料。他定居在费耶特维尔，被那里庞大的意大利移民人口所吸引。尽管他们的生活很幸福，但索德家族仍然面临困难。这让他们开始怀疑身边的某人是否有理由伤害他们。火灾发生前几周的一个凉爽秋日，老乔治突然被敲门声打扰。声音来自前门。站在他门阶上的是一个他不认识的年轻陌生人。
The stranger asked if there was any work going at George's coal trucking business. George regretfully told him no. Instead of leaving, the man meandered towards the rear of the Sotta's farmhouse. George followed close behind, keeping an eye on him. The man then stopped where the building's two fuse boxes were located. George had just had new wiring installed to fit an electric stove for his family. The local power company had recently given the setup the once over, telling him the wiring was installed correctly and functioning properly. The man turned to George and said,
陌生人问乔治的运煤卡车生意有没有招工。乔治遗憾地告诉他没有。那人不仅没有离开，反而踱步走向索德家农舍的后方。乔治紧随其后，盯着他。那人随后停在了建筑物两个保险丝盒所在地。乔治刚刚为家人安装了适合电炉的新电路。当地电力公司最近才对这套装置进行了检查，告诉他电路安装正确且运行正常。那人转身对乔治说：
This is going to cause a fire one day. Without offering any further explanation, the stranger went on his way. In retrospect, George considered this unknown man could be the arsonist, seeking revenge for not being given work. But this was not the only strange encounter at the Sotta's house prior to the fire. A short time after this incident, another man showed up on the Sotta doorstep named Armstead Rossa Long Jr. He was trying to sell family life insurance. When George declined to take out a policy, Long Jr. became furious, yelling at George, Your goddamn house is going up in smoke and your children are going to be destroyed.
“这总有一天会引发火灾。”没有做任何进一步的解释，陌生人便自顾自地走了。回想起来，乔治认为这个未知的男子可能就是纵火犯，因为没有得到工作而寻求报复。但这并不是火灾发生前索德家遇到的唯一奇怪遭遇。这件事发生后不久，另一个人出现在索德家的门阶上，名叫阿姆斯特德·罗萨·长（Armstead Rossa Long Jr.）。他试图推销家庭人寿保险。当乔治拒绝购买保单时，长暴跳如雷，对乔治大喊：“你该死的房子会付之一炬，你的孩子也会被毁掉。”
You are going to pay for the dirty remarks you have been making about Mussolini. This comment took George by surprise, but his views on the Italian fascist leader Benito Mussolini were well known throughout the Italian community in Fayetteville. Although Mussolini was admired by some, George Sotta went out of his way to make known his view that he despised the former dictator, who had been executed nine months before the fire. It was a subject that divided his neighbours, and George was sure it made him some local enemies. Armstead Rossa Long Jr., the man who had threatened George, later served on the coroner's jury who determined the cause of the fire to be faulty wiring. He was never investigated as a suspect, nor was his appearance on the jury with two of his close acquaintances regarded as a conflict of interest. In addition, in the weeks prior to Christmas, as the school-aged children finished up for the year, they approached George and Jenny with a concern. They had seen a man watching them intently from his car that was pulled up alongside the highway as they got off the school bus and walked to their home.
“你会为自己对墨索里尼发表的那些肮脏言论付出代价。”这番话让乔治大吃一惊，但他对意大利法西斯领导人本尼托·墨索里尼的看法在费耶特维尔的意大利社区里是众所周知的。尽管墨索里尼受到一些人的崇拜，但老乔治却特意表明自己鄙视这位在前九个月被处决的前独裁者。这是一个让他的邻居们产生分裂的话题，乔治确信这给他招惹了一些当地的敌人。威胁过乔治的阿姆斯特德·罗萨·长后来担任验尸陪审团成员，该陪审团判定火灾原因是电路故障。他从未被作为嫌疑人进行调查，他与他的两个亲密熟人一起出现在陪审团中也没有被视为利益冲突。此外，在圣诞节前的几周里，随着学龄儿童结束了一年的学业，他们带着一个担忧找到乔治和珍妮。他们看到一个男人从停在公路旁车里紧紧盯着他们，当时他们正下校车走回家。
Initially dismissing their children, the Sotters now wondered if this had anything to do with the fire. One issue that lingered in the minds of the Sotta parents was the lack of human remains uncovered in the aftermath of the fire. One day, Jenny Sotta was reading a newspaper when she came across an article detailing the deaths of a local family of seven in a house fire. All skeletons had been recovered, including that of a three-month-old baby. According to the Sunday Gazette Mail, Jenny Sotta began to experiment. She wanted to see if a fire could completely disintegrate bones, as she had been told by the fire chief following her own tragedy. Jenny took leftovers from dinner, chicken bones, pork chop bones and beef joints, and placed them in a wood-burning stove to see what would happen. After each time, she was left with a pile of burnt, but still visibly intact, bones.
索德夫妇起初并未把孩子们的话放在心上，现在却开始怀疑这是否与火灾有关。索德父母心中挥之不去的一个问题是，火灾过后竟然没有在废墟中发现人类遗骸。一天，珍妮·索德正在读报纸，看到一篇文章详细报道了当地一个七口之家在房屋火灾中丧生的事件。所有的骨骼都被找回了，包括一个三个月大婴儿的骨骼。根据《星期日宪报邮件报》（Sunday Gazette Mail）的报道，珍妮·索德开始做实验。她想看看火是否能像火灾发生后消防队长告诉她的那样，彻底将骨头烧成灰烬。珍妮将晚饭剩下的剩菜——鸡骨头、猪排骨和牛肉关节——放在燃木炉里，看看会发生什么。每次烧完后，她都会留下一堆烧焦但仍然清晰完整的骨头。
Jenny visited a crematorium to discuss her findings. An employee told her that even after burning a human body for two hours at 2,000 degrees, skeletal remains were still present. The fire that consumed the Sotta household did not reach nearly as high a temperature or burn intensely for as long. It left a major question for the Sottas. If the children were in the fire, then where were their remains? 50 miles north of Fayetteville, in the town of Charleston, a woman was reading the local newspaper when she saw an article detailing the fire that killed the Sotta children. Accompanying the piece were the photographs of the five deceased children. The woman recognized four of the five children immediately, having seen them at the hotel where she worked a week after the fire.
珍妮拜访了一家火葬场来讨论她的发现。一名员工告诉她，即使在2000度的高温下焚烧人体两小时，骨骼残骸依然会存在。吞噬索德一家的火灾温度远没有那么高，也没有剧烈燃烧那么长时间。这给索德夫妇留下了一个重大疑问。如果孩子们在火灾中，那么他们的遗骸在哪里？在费耶特维尔以北50英里的查尔斯顿镇，一名妇女正在阅读当地报纸，看到了一篇详细报道这场夺走索德家孩子生命的火灾的文章。随文章附有五个已故孩子的照片。这位妇女立刻认出了五个孩子中的四个，因为在火灾发生后的一周里，她在自己工作的酒店见过他们。
She contacted authorities and assigned an affidavit which read, The children were accompanied by two women and two men, all of Italian extraction. I do not remember the exact date. However, the entire party did register at the hotel and stayed in a large room with several beds. They registered about midnight. I tried to talk to the children in a friendly manner, but the men appeared hostile and refused to allow me to talk to these children. One of the men looked at me in a hostile manner, he turned around and began talking rapidly in Italian. Immediately, the whole party stopped talking to me.
她联系了当局并签署了一份宣誓书，上面写道：“这些孩子由两个女人和两个男人陪同，他们全都是意大利血统。我不记得确切日期。然而，这一行人确实在酒店登记并住在一个有多张床的大房间里。他们大约在半夜登记。我试图以友好的方式与孩子们交谈，但那些男人表现出敌意，拒绝让我和这些孩子们说话。其中一个男人用充满敌意的眼神看着我，他转过身去，开始用意大利语快速交谈。瞬间，整群人都停止了和我说话。”
I sensed that I was being frozen out and so I said nothing more. They left early the next morning. This was not the only alleged sighting that made its way back to George and Jenny Sotta. Another woman came forward to say she served the children breakfast at a tourist stop outside of Fayetteville on the morning of the fire. She also noticed a car with Florida license plates parked outside. This coincided with a later sighting in the commercial fishing village of Cortez, Florida. The local police followed up the leads, but they didn't get far. In 1947, the Sotters, certain that their children had been kidnapped and a fire lit to cover the tracks, wrote to the FBI.
“我感觉到自己被冷落了，所以我没再多说。他们第二天清晨就离开了。”这并不是传到老乔治和珍妮·索德耳朵里的唯一据称的目击事件。另一位妇女站出来说，她在火灾当天的早晨在费耶特维尔郊外的一个旅游休息站为孩子们提供过早餐。她还注意到外面停着一辆挂着佛罗里达州车牌的汽车。这与后来在佛罗里达州科尔特斯商业捕鱼村的目击事件相吻合。当地警方跟进了这些线索，但没有取得什么进展。1947年，索德夫妇确信他们的孩子被绑架了，并且为了掩盖行踪而放火，于是他们写信给联邦调查局（FBI）。
They received a reply from director J. Edgar Hoover. In the letter, he told the Sotters he would like to be of assistance, but it seemed like a local matter not within the jurisdiction of the FBI. However, they agreed to help if permission to investigate was received from the Fayetteville police and fire departments. For reasons unknown, the police and fire departments refused to cooperate. George Sotta followed up the alleged sightings of his children, travelling to the various locations where they were reportedly spotted. But he returned home each time, no closer to finding them. In 1949, he travelled to Manhattan in New York City after seeing a photograph of some schoolchildren in the local newspaper. He became convinced that one of them was his missing daughter, Betty.
他们收到了局长J·埃德加·胡佛的回复。在信中，他告诉索德夫妇他很乐意提供帮助，但这似乎是一个地方事务，不属于联邦调查局的管辖范围。不过，他们同意在获得费耶特维尔警察局和消防部门的调查许可后提供帮助。由于未知原因，警察局和消防部门拒绝合作。老乔治·索德继续追查关于他孩子的目击传闻，前往据称他们被看到的各个地点。但他每次空手而归，离找到他们并没有更近一步。1949年，在看到当地报纸上几名学童的照片后，他前往纽约市曼哈顿。他开始确信其中一人是他失踪的女儿贝蒂。
George tracked down the family, but they refused to talk to him. In order to help chase up leads, George hired private investigator C.C. Tinsley. Tinsley interviewed members of the Fayetteville community. Upon speaking with the local minister, a strange story emerged. The minister reported that the fire chief, F.J. Morris, who investigated the ruins of the Sotta house on Christmas morning, had visited him with a confession. Morris said he had found the remains of a human heart in the ashes that morning, but instead of notifying anyone, he took the heart, placed it inside a box and buried it underneath the rubble of the former Sotta house. C.C. Tinsley confronted the fire chief, who admitted burying the box. Together, they went to the scene and dug around until they located it.
乔治找到了这家人，但他们拒绝跟他谈话。为了协助追查线索，乔治雇用了私家侦探C·C·汀斯利（C.C. Tinsley）。汀斯利采访了费耶特维尔社区的成员。在与当地牧师交谈时，一个奇怪的故事浮出水面。牧师报告说，在圣诞节早晨调查索德家废墟的消防队长F·J·莫里斯曾带着一份供词来找过他。莫里斯说，他在那天早晨的灰烬中发现了人类心脏的残骸，但没有通知任何人，而是把心脏拿走，放进一个盒子里，埋在了索德家旧址的瓦砾下。C·C·汀斯利与消防队长当面对质，后者承认了埋藏盒子的事。他们一起去到现场四处挖掘，直到找到了盒子。
Tinsley sent the box and its contents to a mortician. He examined the specimen and sent a letter summarizing his findings to George Sotta. It wasn't a human heart, but a piece of beef liver. It hadn't even been in a fire. The findings added more confusion to the case. Jenny Sotta revealed that the family hadn't been eating beef liver, nor was there any in their house on the night of the fire. Tinsley returned to fire chief F.J. Morris and told him of the findings. He confessed to burying the liver in the hope that it would be found and put to rest the Sotta family's concerns that their children were still alive somewhere.
汀斯利将盒子及其内容物寄给了一名殡仪师。殡仪师检查了样本，并写了一封信将他的发现总结发送给老乔治·索德。这不是一颗人类的心脏，而是一块牛肝。它甚至根本没有经历过火灾。这一发现给这个案件增添了更多的混乱。珍妮·索德透露，家里根本没有吃过牛肝，火灾当晚家里也没有这种东西。汀斯利回到消防队长F·J·莫里斯那里，把调查结果告诉了他。他承认自己埋下这块肝脏是希望能被找到，从而平息索德一家对于孩子们是否还在某个地方活着的担忧。
When word of the bizarre act got out, others speculated that he buried the organ to put a stop to the investigation. The specimen was never sent back to the Sodders and disappeared, presumably discarded, so no further testing was ever completed. Why he buried the liver in a box was never ascertained. Fire chief F.J. Morris maintained that other human remains were found on the morning of the fire. However, the Sodders refuted this claim, telling the media that they were informed that nothing was found. Writer Stacy Horn reported on her website that elder son John allegedly told police in a statement that he tried to rouse the missing Sotta children who he initially claimed were asleep in the attic when the fire took hold. However, George and Jenny Sotta later disputed this assertion, saying that John reported this out of guilt for running down the attic stairs to escape the blaze without alerting his siblings. As the three-year anniversary of the blaze approached, the Raleigh Register printed an article about the Sotta children and their possible disappearance.
当这个怪异行为的消息传开后，其他人猜测他埋掉这个器官是为了阻止调查。这个样本从未被送回给索德夫妇，并且消失了，据推测已被丢弃，因此再也没有进行过进一步的测试。他为什么把肝脏装在盒子里从未查明。消防队长F·J·莫里斯坚称在火灾早晨发现了其他人骨遗骸。然而，索德夫妇反驳了这一说法，告诉媒体他们被告知什么也没有找到。作家斯黛西·霍恩（Stacy Horn）在她的网站上报道称，大儿子约翰据称在给警察的一份声明中说，他曾试图唤醒他最初声称在火灾发生时正在阁楼睡觉的失踪的索德孩子们。然而，老乔治和珍妮·索德后来对这一说法提出异议，称约翰这样说纯粹是因为没能叫醒兄弟姐妹、自己独自逃离火灾而感到内疚。《罗利纪事报》（Raleigh Register）在火灾三周年纪念日即将来临之际，刊登了一篇关于索德孩子们及其可能失踪的报道。
Titled Mysterious Fate of Five Children Pondered, it listed further evidence that the children might still be alive. Evidence included a girl who came forward to say she had seen one of the supposedly dead children looking out a car window while the fire was in progress. Another private detective hired by the Sodders named George Swain theorized in the article that the children might have been lured from the house under the pretense of attending a Christmas party. They were then kidnapped for sale on the black market. He added that he had interviewed witnesses who were at the fire on whether they smelled burning flesh or heard screams coming from the house. All those he interviewed said they hadn't. However, the strong winds that night may have accounted for this. The article ended with a quote from the editor. It is the truth, not sympathy, that Mr and Mrs Sotta seek.
这篇题为《五名儿童的神秘命运引发思考》的文章列举了孩子们可能仍然活着的更多证据。证据包括一个站出来的女孩，她说她看见其中一个据称已经死亡的孩子在火灾进行时正透过车窗往外看。索德夫妇雇用的另一位名叫乔治·斯温（George Swain）的私家侦探在文章中推测，这些孩子可能是以参加圣诞派对为借口被诱骗出屋的。随后他们被绑架并贩卖到黑市。他补充说，他曾采访过火灾现场的目击者，询问他们是否闻到烧焦的肉味或听到来自房屋的尖叫声。所有他采访的人都说没有。然而，当晚的强劲大风或许可以解释这一点。文章以编辑的一句话结束：“索德先生和夫人寻求的是真相，而不是同情。”
They want to know whether their children are living or dead. The parents shall believe their lost ones are alive until proven dead. This story is published in the hope that somewhere, somehow, it will bring forth information that will end the agonizing doubts for the parents. Either through a happy reunion with their children, or definite establishment that the children did meet death in the fire. After three years working on the Sotta case, private investigator George Swain announced in September 1949 that he was stepping down from the case. He told the Beckley Post-Herald that he had nowhere left to turn. He said, My three years' work on this mystery leaves the matter unsolved, in spite of the fact I worked diligently in probing every known lead in the face of utter frustration met at every turn. Many mysterious circumstances will puzzle me forever. My efforts in a large measure were prompted by sympathy for the bereaved parents, and I regret that I was unable to bring them even a crumb of solace in the bereavement.
“他们想知道他们的孩子是生是死。在证实死亡之前，做父母的会一直相信他们失踪的孩子还活着。发表这个故事是希望能通过某种方式、在某个地方，带来能够结束父母痛苦煎熬的信息。无论是通过与孩子们幸福团聚，还是明确确定孩子们确实在火灾中丧生。”经过三年对索德案的调查，私家侦探乔治·斯温于1949年9月宣布退出此案。他告诉《贝克利邮报先驱报》（Beckley Post-Herald），他已经无路可走。他说：“我在这桩谜团上花了三年时间，却依然毫无头破，尽管我在每一个转折处都遭遇彻底的挫折，但我依然勤奋地探查了每一条已知的线索。许多神秘的情况将永远困扰着我。我的努力在很大程度上是出于对痛失爱子的父母的同情，我很遗憾没能给他们带来哪怕一丝慰藉。”
My heart goes out to the Sotta family. I have been guided by advice from some of the nation's most noted experts on Asim, pathologists and criminologists, and I feel that many of the mysteries surrounding the fire never will be solved. I believe it is utterly foolish to spend any more money on a search that is bound to prove fruitless. As I see it now, the question is not whether the children perished in the flames, but what became of the bones following the fire. Despite the resignation of the lead investigator on the case, the Sotters refused to give up searching for their children. On September 11, 1953, nearly eight years after the fire, George and Jenny put up a billboard on their property which was visible to those driving along Highway Route 16. Adorning the billboard were the black and white photos of Morris, Martha, Lewis, Jenny and Betty Sotter. Above the five photos in large capitals was the question, what was their fate, kidnapped, murdered, or are they still alive?
“我的心与索德一家同在。我一直听取全国最著名的关于阿西姆、病理学家和犯罪学家的专家的建议，我觉得围绕这场火灾的许多谜团永远不会被解开。我认为把更多的钱花在一个注定徒劳无功的搜寻上是极其愚蠢的。依我之见，现在的问题不是孩子们是否在烈火中丧生，而是火灾过后骨头去了哪里。”尽管案件的主导调查员辞职了，但索德夫妇拒绝放弃搜寻他们的孩子。1943年9月11日，在火灾发生近八年后，乔治和珍妮在他们的土地上竖起了一块广告牌，过往16号公路的司机都可以看到它。广告牌上装饰着莫里斯、玛莎、刘易斯、珍妮和贝蒂·索德的黑白照片。五张照片上方用醒目的大写字母写着这样一个问题：“他们的命运如何：被绑架、谋杀，还是他们仍然活着？”
Alongside was the announcement of a $5,000 reward. In addition, the Sotters printed out flyers with the children's photos and information, hoping to circulate the images as far as possible. The billboard made local news with the Beckley Post-Herald reporting. Sotter says he cannot understand the lack of interest shown by authorities in the case. He has had to pay for and push what investigating has been done. However, the family has pledged all in its power to solve this mystery. The family is not particularly interested in punishing anyone if there was foul play. They state they would be glad to waive charges or to sign any kind of release asked for if they could only regain their children or learn what happened to them.
旁边是悬赏5000美元的公告。此外，索德夫妇还印制了带有孩子们照片和信息的传单，希望尽可能广泛地传播这些影像。这块广告牌登上了当地新闻，《贝克利邮报先驱报》报道称：“索德表示，他无法理解当局对该案缺乏兴趣。他不得不自掏腰包并推动已经进行的调查。然而，该家族已誓言要尽一切力量解开这个谜团。如果存在谋杀或虐待，这个家族对惩罚任何人并没有特别大的兴趣。他们表示，如果能找回他们的孩子或得知他们发生了什么事，他们很乐意放弃指控或签署任何被要求的释放协议。”
Over the years, the billboard was carefully maintained by George and Jenny Sotter and repainted with new messages now and again, each time pleading for information on their children. One tip came in from a woman in Houston, Texas, who sent a letter to the Sotters. According to Medium.com, she maintained an acquaintance of hers had confessed to being Louis Sotter and told her he was living with his brother Morris, both of whom were listed as deceased in the fire. George traveled to the area but was unable to locate the woman who sent the letter. The local police managed to help George find the man who confessed to being Louis, but he denied ever making the confession. One day in 1968, 22 years after the fire, Jenny Sotter went to collect her mail. Rummaging through the various letters, one envelope caught her eye. It had her name on it, but no return address.
多年来，这块广告牌一直由老乔治和珍妮·索德精心维护，并不时刷上新的信息，每一次都在恳求有关他们孩子的信息。其中一条线索来自德克萨斯州休斯顿的一位妇女，她给索德夫妇寄了一封信。据Medium.com报道，她坚称她的一个熟人曾坦白自己就是刘易斯·索德，并告诉她自己正和哥哥莫里斯住在一起，而这两人在火灾中都被列为已故。乔治前往该地区，但未能找到寄信的妇女。当地警察设法帮乔治找到了那个自称是刘易斯的男子，但他否认自己曾做过这样的坦白。1968年的一天，即火灾发生22年后，珍妮·索德去取信。在各种信件中翻找时，一个信封吸引了她的目光。上面写着她的名字，但没有回信地址。
A postmark revealed it had been sent from Central City, Kentucky. When Jenny opened the letter, she realized it had already been opened and resealed, similar to previous letters she had received in the past. Inside was a single black and white photograph showing the upper body and face of a man in his late 20s to early 30s. On the back, someone had scrawled. Louis Sotter, I love brother Frankie, L-L-I-L, boys, A90132 or 35. The cryptic message meant nothing to the Sotters and there was no child named Frankie in their family. However, from the moment they laid eyes on the photo, George and Jenny were convinced that they were looking at their son Louis, who was 9 years old at the time of the fire. He bore a striking similarity to the photo of Louis as a child that was still situated on the billboard.
邮戳显示它是从肯塔基州中央城寄出的。当珍妮打开信时，她意识到它已经被打开并重新封好过，类似于她过去收到的信件。里面只有一张黑白照片，显示一个20多岁到30岁出头男人的上半身和脸。背面有人乱涂乱画写着：“刘易斯·索德，我爱弟弟弗兰基（Frankie），L-L-I-L，男孩们，A90132或35。”这个神秘的信息对索德夫妇来说毫无意义，他们的家族中也没有叫弗兰基的孩子。然而，从他们看到这张照片的那一刻起，乔治和珍妮就确信他们看到的是他们的儿子刘易斯，火灾发生时他9岁。他与挂在广告牌上刘易斯小时候的照片有着惊人的相似之处。
The Sotters made a copy of the photograph to add on to the billboard and another which they framed and hung in pride of place in their home. They hired a private investigator to follow the lead to Central City, Kentucky, paying him upfront for his services. George and Jenny never heard from him again. As 1968 drew to a close, the Sotters had spent over $15,000 of their own money to chase up leads, pay private investigators and promote their children's disappearance. They increased the reward for information to $10,000. George told the Sunday Gazette, It's hard sometimes to get to sleep at night, just wondering about them. After all, if someone wanted to get me, why did they get my family too?
索德夫妇复印了一张照片贴在广告牌上，另一张则装裱起来，挂在他们家里最显眼的地方。他们雇了一名私家侦探去肯塔基州中央城跟进这条线索，并提前支付了服务费。乔治和珍妮再也没有听到过他的消息。随着1968年接近尾声，索德夫妇已经花费了超过1.5万美元的私房钱来追查线索、支付私家侦探费用以及宣传他们孩子的失踪。他们将提供线索的悬赏金提高到了1万美元。乔治对《星期日宪报》说：“有时候晚上很难入睡，就是忍不住想他们。毕竟，如果有人想对付我，为什么连我的家人也一起害呢？”
But as long as we live, we will dig into it, to come out with an explanation on what really happened 23 years ago in that fire. George Sotter died a year later on August 16, 1969, at age 73. After his death, Jenny continued to display the billboard at the Sotter property. Over the years, it became weathered and run down. Jenny, who had worn black exclusively ever since the fire as a sign of mourning to her five children, became more reclusive. As reported in the Smithsonian magazine, she began to have more and more rooms built on the existing Sotter house, in an attempt to distance herself further from the outside world. Jenny tended the memorial garden, planted at the site of their former home, ensuring that the flowers thrived. Jenny Sotter died in 1989, at the age of 85.
“但只要我们活着，我们就会追查到底，为23年前那场火灾中真正发生的事情给出一个解释。”老乔治·索德于一年后（1969年8月16日）去世，享年73岁。他去世后，珍妮继续在索德家的财产上展示这块广告牌。多年来，它变得风化破旧。珍妮自从火灾以来一直穿着黑衣作为对五个孩子的哀悼标志，变得越来越隐居。据《史密森尼》杂志报道，她开始在现有的索德房子上建造越来越多的房间，试图将自己与外界进一步隔离开来。珍妮悉心照料在旧址上种植的纪念花园，确保花朵繁茂生长。珍妮·索德于1989年去世，享年85岁。
She was buried next to George at Highlawn Memorial Park in Fayette County. George Sotter's headstone reads, Who believed in justice for everyone, but was denied justice by the law when his five children were kidnapped Christmas Eve 1945 at Fayetteville, West Virginia. In the years following their mother's death, the remaining Sotter children continued to follow up leads and promote the story of the fire that changed their lives forever. Some developed the theory that the fire was orchestrated by the Italian mafia, who were supportive of Benito Mussolini. Or that the local mafia had tried to recruit George and he had declined, prompting them to seek revenge. According to the Smithsonian magazine, another theory was that the five missing Sotter children had been kidnapped by someone they knew, who told them of the fire and offered to take them somewhere safe. They speculated that perhaps they were alive and had not contacted their siblings in order to protect them.
她被安葬在费耶特县的高草坪纪念公园乔治的旁边。老乔治·索德的墓碑上写着：“他相信人人享有公正，但在1945年平安夜他的五个孩子在西弗吉尼亚州费耶特维尔被绑架时，法律剥夺了他的公正。”在他们母亲去世后的几年里，剩下的索德孩子们继续跟进线索，并宣传这起永远改变了他们生活的火灾故事。一些人形成了这样一种理论：火灾是由支持本尼托·墨索里尼的意大利黑手党精心策划的。或者当地黑手党曾试图招募乔治而遭到拒绝，从而促使他们寻求报复。据《史密森尼》杂志报道，另一种理论是，这五个失踪的索德孩子被他们认识的人绑架了，那人告诉他们火灾的事并提出带他们去安全的地方。他们推测也许他们还活着，只是为了保护他们而没有与兄弟姐妹联系。
Sylvia Sotter, the youngest surviving Sotter child, is now in her late 70s. She is the only known Sotter child still alive. According to Medium.com, Sylvia is certain that her siblings did not perish in the fire. She still browsers online blogs dedicated to finding out what happened to her family in the hope of getting some answers before she passes. Although Sylvia was only three at the time of the fire, she can still remember her father's bleeding arm. She has also never forgotten the screams of those who escaped the inferno, watching helplessly as it destroyed their lives forever. One event that came the closest to solving the mystery of what happened to the Sotter children occurred in August 1949, nearly four years after the fire. In desperation to find any evidence that would prove to him that his children perished in the blaze, George Sotter hired a small crew and excavated the site he had previously filled over with dirt. Watching as George removed the soil with a bulldozer was a Washington DC pathologist named Oscar B Hunter, whom the Sotters had hired for his expert opinion.
作为索特家幸存的最小孩子，西尔维娅·索特现在已经70多岁了。她是目前已知的唯一还活着的索特家的孩子。据Medium.com报道，西尔维娅坚信她的兄弟姐妹并没有在大火中丧生。她仍然浏览专门寻找她的家人遭遇的在线博客，希望能在他离世前得到一些答案。尽管火灾发生时西尔维娅只有三岁，但她依然记得父亲流血的手臂。她也从未忘记那些从烈火中逃生的人的尖叫声，他们眼睁睁地看着大火永远摧毁了他们的生活。最接近解开索特家孩子失踪之谜的事件发生在1949年8月，距离火灾发生近四年。为了找到能证明他的孩子在大火中丧生的任何证据，乔治·索特雇佣了一小队人，对他之前用泥土填埋的现场进行了挖掘。华盛顿特区的一名病理学家奥斯卡·B·亨特（Oscar B Hunter）受索特夫妇之托，作为专家顾问在现场观看乔治用推土机铲除泥土。
As printed in the Raleigh Register, he told George that had the children perished in the fire, he expected their skulls would be located. No Fayetteville County officials attended the scene aside from a deputy sheriff who watched on and didn't participate. Excavating to a depth of five feet, the crew combed through the dirt and rubble to find human remains. They found several coins that had been burned but were still recognizable, a damaged dictionary, bits of roofing and other small objects that had not been impacted by the blaze. Then, they uncovered some bones. The skeletal remains, which appeared to be vertebrae, were sent to the Smithsonian Institute for analysis. The report, which was sent to the Sotters, concluded The human bones consist of four lumbar vertebrae belonging to one individual.
正如《罗利纪事报》所报道的那样，他对乔治说，如果孩子们在大火中丧生，他预计会找到他们的头骨。除了一个在旁观看但没有参与的副警长外，没有任何费耶特维尔县的官员出席现场。挖掘深度达到五英尺，挖掘队在泥土和瓦砾中仔细搜寻人类遗骸。他们找到了几枚被烧焦但仍可辨认的硬币、一本受损的字典、几片屋顶碎片以及其他未受大火影响的小物件。接着，他们发现了一些骨头。这具骨骼遗骸看起来像是脊椎骨，被送往史密森尼学会进行分析。这份发送给索特夫妇的报告得出结论：人类骨骼由属于一个人的四节腰椎组成。
Since the transverse recesses are fused, the age of this individual at death should have been 16 or 17 years. The top limit of age should be about 22, since the centra, which normally fused at 23, are still unfused. The oldest Sotter child determined to have perished in the fire was 14-year-old Morris. The report continued On this basis, the bones show greater skeletal maturation than one would expect for a 14-year-old boy. The vertebrae showed no evidence that they had been exposed to fire, and it is very strange that no other bones were found in the allegedly careful excavation of the basement of the house. One would expect to find the full skeletons of the five children, rather than only four vertebrae. This was a sentiment echoed by many professionals who were called upon to give their opinion over the years following the fire.
由于横突已经融合，这个人在去世时的年龄应该是16或17岁。年龄的上限应该在大约22岁，因为通常在23岁才融合的椎体此时尚未融合。经确定在大火中丧生的索特家最大的孩子是14岁的莫里斯。报告继续写道：基于这一点，这些骨骼表现出的骨骼成熟度高于人们对一个14岁男孩的预期。脊椎骨没有显示出曾受火烧的迹象，而且在据称仔细挖掘房屋地下室的过程中没有发现其他骨头，这非常奇怪。人们本应期望找到五个孩子的完整骨骼，而不是只有四节脊椎。火灾发生后的几年里，许多被请来发表意见的专业人士也表达了同样的看法。
In a 15-year anniversary article printed in the Beckley Post-Herald on Christmas Day 1960, a pathologist said I wouldn't say it's impossible, but it's highly improbable. I have seen about 120 burning deaths, and there were always some remains left. Another pathologist who wished to remain anonymous was quoted as saying No ordinary house fire could completely consume five bodies. The findings prompted two hearings about the Sotter case in the West Virginian capital of Charleston. However, the governor and state police superintendent closed the case due to lack of evidence. The vertebrae were not returned to the Sotters, and the report concluded that the bones likely came from the dirt that George Sotter used to cover over the rubble of the fire.
在1960年圣诞节出版的《贝克利信使邮报》15周年纪念文章中，一位病理学家说：我不会说这是不可能的，但这是高度不可能的。我见过大约120起烧死案，总是会留下一些遗骸。另一位希望保持匿名的病理学家被引述说：没有哪场普通的房屋火灾能够彻底吞噬五具尸体。这些发现引发了西弗吉尼亚州首府查尔斯顿关于索特案的两次听证会。然而，由于缺乏证据，州长和州警察局长结了案。脊椎骨没有归还给索特夫妇，报告得出结论认为，这些骨头很可能来自乔治·索特用来覆盖火灾废墟的泥土。
As the remains have long since disappeared, this raises another question that will forever be unanswered. If the bones weren't from the Sotter children, then who did they belong to? When Jenny Sotter died in 1989, her remaining children took down the billboard she and George had erected in an effort to find out what exactly had happened to 14-year-old Morris, 12-year-old Martha, 9-year-old Lewis, 8-year-old Jenny, and 5-year-old Betty. It had read, On Christmas Eve 1945, our home was set afire and five of our children, ages 5 through 14, kidnapped. The officials blamed defective wiring, although lights were still burning after the fire started. The official report stated that the children died in the fire. However, no bones were found in the residue, and there was no smell of burning flesh during or after the fire.
由于遗骸早已消失，这就提出了另一个永远无法回答的问题。如果这些骨头不属于索特家的孩子，那它们属于谁呢？当珍妮·索特于1989年去世时，她剩下的孩子拆除了她和乔治竖起的巨型广告牌，他们曾试图通过这个广告牌弄清楚14岁的莫里斯、12岁的玛莎、9岁的刘易斯、8岁的珍妮和5岁的贝蒂到底遭遇了什么。上面写着：在1945年的平安夜，我们的家被纵火烧毁，我们五个5到14岁的孩子被绑架了。官员们归咎于电路故障，尽管火灾发生后灯依然亮着。官方报告称，孩子们死于火灾。然而，残骸中没有发现骨头，火灾期间或之后也没有闻到烧焦的肉味。
What was the motive of the law officers involved? What did they have to gain by making us suffer all these years of injustice? Why did they lie and force us to accept those lies? Copyright© OSHO International Foundation www.OSHO.com OSHO is a registered Trademark of OSHO International Foundation There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
涉案执法人员的动机是什么？多年来让我们遭受这种不公正待遇，他们得到了什么？他们为什么要撒谎并迫使我们接受这些谎言？Copyright© OSHO International Foundation www.OSHO.com OSHO 是 OSHO International Foundation 的注册商标。目前本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。